foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
every living thing on it has evolved
together over
time
[Music]
and although we are part of the web of
life
because we see it
we think we stand above it
from all that nature gave us we have
made a new world out of wilderness
built great civilizations
[Music]
it seemed there was nothing we could not
do
the sky itself
was not the limit
we see the symptoms of a reality we
didn't expect
and we reached the limitations of our
human nature
is this the end of the line for us
it's hard to tell from our current point
of view living here in the Future's Past
foreign
the world that we live in is just this
shockingly blue sphere
when you see the space you understand
there's a planet that's bowling around
the Sun turning on this axis the oceans
clouds mountains forests you can see it
all from up there you can see over a
thousand miles in any direction and it's
all moving underneath you at five miles
per second
when you look at the Horizon you see a
very very thin
Little Blue Ribbon of atmosphere
it really brings home to you it was a
shock to me and I'm a scientist okay I
thought I had all the scales worked out
intellectually but it was a shock to me
to see how thin the atmosphere is and
how obviously it's easily affected by
what we do
this is a great challenge of our time
dealing with the human impact on the
environment and what it means in terms
of our civilization going forward
we cut all the trees
would kill all the fish
we consume and consume
so much ecological writing you know just
opened the paper is about the end of the
world is that it's starting like when's
it going to start I'm under you know
three two one and the concept world as a
sort of way of distinguishing between
human beings and everything else has
evaporated
this is the only place that we know out
of this whole universe
that we can live
life is messy we are changing multiple
aspects of the earth environment
predicting all of the effects of it is
incredibly complicated
what do we do
we've been standing back and watching
nature decline before our very eyes it's
on everyone's mind is why are we not
doing more in response we've used our
abilities to build a huge technological
Society that's very advanced
but in our Essence we're still animals
and one of the problems is that as
animals we have certain emotions and
certain tendencies
that are counterproductive in our great
complex society
Spinoza the philosopher said man doesn't
really understand all the unconscious
processes which actually really control
their conscious behaviors and thoughts
perhaps the solutions we're looking for
start in US
in our genes
our subconscious motivations
our most Primal instincts
we are the most flexible species
ever evolved I would think
and when you see people thriving in the
Arctic and you see people thriving in
the Kalahari Desert and you see people
thriving in the Amazon rainforest these
are Titanic accomplishments
but we also have the ability to destroy
all of those habitats and everything in
between
[Music]
can looking at Evolution help us
understand the current conscious self we
have
in the future of humanity
[Music]
from an evolutionary perspective humans
are just another species we're unique
but evolutionary biology sees every
species as unique
every species everywhere is a genius at
survival otherwise it wouldn't be here
every species can teach us something
when you look at all the different life
forms the plants and the animals they
just seem so different to each other but
of course we're all made the same stuff
the atoms which make the molecules which
produce the DNA and the diversity is
down to this process of natural
selection
so we know that natural selection has
allowed diversity to appear as the
process of winning out those who are
most suited to the environments natural
selection has evolved different lineages
of organisms and we are at the top of
one of those lineages
the further animals doesn't mean that
underneath our sophisticated
civilization we are these utilitarian
lumps it's exactly the opposite what it
means is that being sophisticated and
artistic goes all the way down at least
to the level of beetles with iridescent
wind cases
because there's something intrinsically
non utilitarian and playful about
evolution
we're part of the system or nature we're
part of the earth and we're
fundamentally dependent
on his good graces
very symbiotic relationship
through everything on this Earth
and I understand some people the face
say no no this is a science thing is not
for us it's that's that's the province
of God we shouldn't go there I can I I
can hear that view but I really don't
think it's um what I see in scripture
what I think in scripture is come on I
want to show it to you I want to reveal
myself to you
I don't see science is challenging my
faith in fact I see it as affirming my
faith
[Music]
we are new on the planet we are the most
newly evolved we're a trial run in terms
of evolution uh animals adapt to their
ecological conditions but as humans we
have been able to control our ecological
conditions
Evolution itself is a process by which
organisms become more efficient at
extracting resources from their
environment
humans are unique and that what makes us
so different from all of other animals
is our Mastery of Technology we are
uniquely able to transform our
environment in ways no other animals can
we humans are really big brain primates
that lucked out by becoming bipedal and
discovering how to coerce other animals
from a distance by being able to throw
we figured out how to tame fire and use
it to our advantage our evolving
technology allowed us to expand into new
territories and manipulate the
environment in ways that gave us an edge
that places like this remind me about
how harsh nature can be we're so used to
living in air conditioning and having
the comfort of the modern world
but when you go out into nature and
experience it firsthand
you're reminded very powerfully about
how weak we are as an animal
and this is because we are fundamentally
a cultural species
culture is our life support system
[Music]
our cumulative culture allows us to
cushion ourselves against the harsh
realities of the environment and to
reshape the environment
our culture is an integral part of our
ecology
Trace human ancestors back over 4
million years and anatomically modern
humans for more than 200 000 years
inherited their successful survival
traits
parades are in all of us to some extent
traits like optimizing time
really caring about what other people
think about us and comparing ourselves
to others
[Music]
we are still trying to attain the same
daily emotional state as our successful
ancestors
carry the same neurotransmitters in our
brains that created the exhilarating
feeling our ancient ancestors got when
they had the unexpected reward of
finding a bearing or a nut over looking
forward to a successful hunt
but in a culture of amazing technology
we are surrounded by ready-made stimuli
pushing us to reward ourselves
our evolutionary impulses can be easily
hijacked
irrespective of where you grew up in the
world it's in our DNA to copy those
around us for humans imitation is part
and parcel of what it is to be a member
of a tribe
now our adaptations are primarily to the
cultural environment we've created
around us if we don't fit into our
culture we're not going to reproduce
we're not going to survive very well
we're going to be ostracized and being
ostracized in a social species like ours
feel like a death sentence
we have a human brain mismatched between
how we evolve to be here and the modern
circumstances we find ourselves in
or our needs any different from our
ancestors
need the word can mean strongly desire
content like I really need a bar of
chocolate and I'm afraid to say that
from my point of view I'm sure
neanderthals would have totally loved
Coca-Cola zero like they look really
good and pure because they didn't have
it you know it's us poor saps but
presumably they got the same nervous
system if it's true that neanderthals
would have also become addicted to Angry
Birds
there's something true in contemporary
Society contemporary Society is saying
something true about ancient people
foreign
this is a modern human brain and as far
as we can tell it's identical to the
brain of individuals who lived 50 000
years ago but of course the information
which is stored in the modern brain is
very different to that of our ancestors
the brain really basically encodes
information and that information will
change from one generation to the next
so you can see the course of human
evolution as the accumulation of wisdom
and knowledge that we pass on from one
generation to the next
all right
our perceptual system isn't attuned to
the massive changes that are happening
on the planet nor are they attuned to
the very fine-grained details of those
changes our brains alarm system for
threat the amygdala the emotional
centers are very tuned to these earlier
dangers the time when that rustle in the
bushes might be a tiger that was about
to eat you
or today's you know symbolic realities
I'm not being treated fair or honey we
have to talk or whatever it is that
triggers you
we have a very quick system that is sort
of dealing with gut reactions with
reflex responses with an instant
response to Danger
and on the other hand we have a slower
more deliberative system which takes
time to engage and which is slow and
ponderous
that we should keep engaged when we're
looking at complex issues in the world
around us
[Music]
it's terrible
we are physical and biological beings
living in an ocean of cosmic energy
that sounds pretty trippy and it is
where every part contains information
about the whole
The Long View is both forward and back
foreign
[Music]
99.9 of our evolutionary history we were
hunting and Gathering people living in
small kin groups where everybody was
related to everybody and therefore we
had a vested interest in taking care of
each other we also lived off of the land
in such a way that we did not live
beyond the carrying capacity of the
environment
there was no way to store food for long
periods of time and therefore there was
no ability to acquire Surplus
what this resulted in was it created a
very egalitarian social system where
women had autonomy there was no real
rigid dominance hierarchy among men
and it was only after the invention of
agriculture and the domestication of
plants and animals that humans were
faced with the situation of what to do
with these Surplus resources
[Music]
this was the beginning of the Neolithic
Revolution we started farming for the
first time
everything took off from there and
that's only been around 12 000 years
that's a blink of an eye an evolutionary
terms
controlling the production and
distribution of these Surplus resources
led to a change in human culture on
social organization
cultural evolution is a transferable
system a lot like DNA
it has all the properties of an evolving
system
since we found agriculture things
changed and we we started to act like a
larger entity just like an ant colony or
a termite Colony or a beehive
foreign
ants are individual organisms performing
different roles
they Rush about to feed or defend the
colony
and collectively they create a super
organism
of course humans are not social insects
but if you were able to watch a village
or a city from a distance over time
it looks a lot like a growing
interdependent super organism
a reorganization of material existence
with far-reaching implications
today we live in a world of material
abundance and inexpensive energy
and this leads us to think that this is
normal for humans that it's the normal
human condition
early societies even through the Middle
Ages and up until almost the modern era
had 90 of their economies devoted to the
production of energy primarily in the
form of food that meant that ninety
percent of what people did involved
producing energy in other words just
getting by
our lives were based on solar flows
sunlight hit the earth photosynthesis
grew the plants rain and soil with the
nutrients grew crops animals ate the
crops and we ate the animals
energy transforms from one state to
another
our bodies were a product of the current
sunlight of the day
and we are just transient entities which
appear move a little bit and then
disappear that's that's the way the
system works and we have this chance to
be alive
to move on this planet to do things on
this planet to create things on this
planet because we have this gigantic
flux of energy coming from the Sun
the whole universe is a giant machine
for dispersing energy potentials
energy is everything in the sense that
nothing moves in the universe without an
energy potential development
[Music]
we have been also able to increase this
already very large amount of energy by
means of using ancient processes at
Frozen
below the ground in the Earth's crust in
the form of what we call fossil fuels
[Music]
fossil sunlight is so powerful it's
indistinguishable from Magic
and we're mining this ancient sunlight
in a very brief period of human history
[Music]
a chemical composition of 50 percent of
the protein in our bodies and eighty
percent of the nitrogen in our bodies
indirectly comes from the chemical
signature of this fossil sunlight that
we're mining
so we are different than our ancestors
they were made of sunlight we are made
of fossil fuels in hunting and Gathering
societies solar energy can provide
enough food to support maybe one person
per square mile
basic subsistence agriculture can
support more people but nowhere near the
population densities that we have today
the way we live is an anomaly
so there's really no way for for anyone
to know at a sort of a visceral level
that there are any problems with the
system and if you look around it all
works
foreign
we know historically I mean to the
extent that we even pay attention to it
we used to use wood we're sort of aware
that our predecessors used wood and they
used so much of it they had to switch to
something else
switched to coal
and then they switched to oil 80 years
ago the oil in America was just under
the surface
we would need very little Machinery to
get these gusher Wells that we would get
out over 100 times the energy that we
put in
[Music]
suddenly this whole new world of
Transportation opened up and with that
came this entirely new model for how we
fed ourselves how we clothed ourselves
how we built shelter and it totally
changed the way we live
we've made it possible for us to move
away from the country
throughout human history and we had to
live sort of scattered in order to not
tax any particular resource too greatly
as we began to be able to import food or
import energy we can pretty much live
where we wanted to and where we wanted
to live we're in the cities so we have
this massive migration we empty the
countryside
we all moved to the city because we're
growing food in the country and we can
just transport it to the city and you
can once you're in the city then you can
do all these other things
you know you can create all this
knowledge you can create Technologies
you can create this massive economic
growth and the longer you've been living
that way the harder it is to remember
what allowed it to start in the first
place and that was this idea of cheap
energy
humans gradually became a functional
super organism at first we would
maximize grain Surplus
we would grow more grain and store it
and that would allow our population to
increase in our territory to expand
but now we're maximizing Surplus value
we're maximizing Financial digital
electronic representations of surplus
but all money really effectively is is a
claim on some Energy Services
and so what ends up happening is
money
trade technology are all in service of
the super organisms
[Music]
it's nearly impossible for individuals
to function independently in modern
society
contribute to and rely on a growing
super organism to feed us to clothe us
power our sophisticated Communications
even protect our societies from each
other through highly organized Warfare
we live within a mesh of energy eating
interdependence
we never really see the big picture
a state of Plenty can have unintended
consequences
reduce the Paradox of our times
[Music]
running in the background of all that we
do whether we consider ourselves to be
capitalist or Soviet or feudal or
everything is the kind of program
a kind of recipe a kind of algorithm
the logistical functioning of Neolithic
society which started all over the world
the trouble is that when you put off
friends repeat eventually when you do it
enough times it starts to reveal its
flaws
for example me starting my car is
statistically meaningless from a global
warming point of view billions and
billions of car ignition turnings has a
meaning and that's the Paradox all of a
sudden we realize that we're part of a
super organism we are enmeshed in
systems of production systems of
manufacture systems of use
[Music]
it's incredibly important to recognize
that we're all
part of the system
as social organisms we're something like
ants
our signals that we exchange are far
more complicated than the simple
chemical signals that ants Exchange
but we do exchange signals and as humans
we take individual actions that on the
whole cause emergent Behavior but the
problem that's happening today is that
the emergent behavior is growing very
complex and detrimental to the planet to
ourselves and to many other species
emergent behaviors all around us
and can be fast-moving and unpredictable
no one could foresee our patterns of
interaction would lead to the internet
smartphone
The Disappearance of phone booths and
the rise of server Farms
knows what will happen next
yeah
we're all in this together maybe if
you're off the grid and truly walking
everywhere you go maybe then you have a
right to polish your Halo We're tiny
little microbes on the surface of this
huge planet we can actually affect the
planet and cause it to respond
[Music]
if we don't stop
a mini carbon dioxide at these rates
pretty soon we're going to be in trouble
we're going to have massive climatic
disruption the rainfall belts will move
people in the hundreds of millions maybe
a billion and a half people will have
problems getting access to fresh water
and food
the issue is not what the world is like
when it's cold or when it's warm
we are in a time of change what is
interesting is how the world changes
when you dramatically in our case
increase the concentration of carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere or When It suffers
Mammoth biodiversity loss caused by our
own behavior
if there's a big change coming and we
want to know what it might do in the
future what do we do we look at what's
happened in the past geological history
largely reinforces the lessons from the
climate models when they say the
doubling of carbon dioxide will lead to
about two and a half degrees three
degrees of warming the history of the
earth is broadly in agreement with that
so a lot of my own research is focused
on the Reconstruction of past climate
we look at dramatic transitions
and there's not a lot of those because
in Earth history things change gradually
three years ago I started on a project
it was to look at an event that was
about 120 million years ago and it was
it was to explore exactly this it was
what we generally considered a rapid
ocean acidification event a rapid
warming event and we thought let's look
at this and see what happened
and as we studied it more and more and
we got better and better age models we
got better and better reconstructions of
the climate change became apparent that
this particular event that happened
about 100 million years ago the climate
change happened
over about 40 000 years
this is the same degree of climate
change that we think might happen over
the next 100 years
[Music]
there's much more energy in the system
we have
very little knowledge of how Earth's
biological life support systems will
respond to dramatic and Rapid change
we have extraordinary biomes on the
planet
that all are individual pieces of a
jigsaw
picture is clear when they're all
functional and all and all present but
start picking those pieces off
and you can no longer see really what
that picture looks like and the
functionality of the entire system is
out of whack
foreign
shrinking
the Greenland ice masses being lost at
300 gigatons a year that's 300 cubic
kilometers of ICU is disappearing
the ocean's changing sea level rise
we're seeing significant sea level
rights we're expecting a couple of feet
maybe more before the end of the century
so all these things are facts
it's not so much to change itself but
it's how fast it's happening faster the
change comes the less time we have to
adapt the faster the change comes the
less time the trees have to adapt or
Plankton live in the ocean
the faster the change comes the less
time ecosystems have to adapt
and the more complexities are the harder
it is to actually predict what the
consequences of that change will be
climate change is going to put huge
stress
on societies that are already under
internal political stress
and stress induced by lack of resources
like food availability water
availability dramatic events associated
with climate change all of which
potentially will exacerbate the
divisions in society access to wealth
creates divisions access to food and
water makes divisions very pronounced
going to impact the way humans live on
the planet when that impacts then people
move people are angry land becomes less
valuable or more valuable populations
shift and those shifts destabilize
governments
[Music]
we might look up at night and wonder at
the far away stars as if we were in a
pristine Crystal snow globe
foreign but our problems can no longer
be pushed into the backyard of the less
powerful less fortunate Among Us
no here we are and here we remain
where everything from Farmers dogs LED
lights flowers pencils politicians
microwaves and Penguins
past present and future are all
interrelated
[Music]
in the next 10 years we shall increase
our wealth by 50 percent
the profound question is
does this mean we will be 50 richer
a real sense
50 better off
50 happier
and so to just give more facts about
climate change or about oil depletion or
about environmental destruction people
don't know what to do because they're
part of this organism trying to get more
feel-good brain chemicals
the treadmill is getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller and the number of people who
want to be on the treadmill is getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger and eventually there's going
to be no room to run and so people will
fall off
many people will fall off
we are profoundly motivated by having
purpose we're motivated by having a
sense of autonomy efficacy and control
where it seems that our gifts our energy
our our life force is not going to have
some impact we will simply withdraw and
we will very likely redirect that energy
into where we can feel we have most
impact
and where is that in our culture right
now it's in consumption
The Economist Emmanuel wallerstein has
talked about world systems theory in
which all things are connected for
better and often for worse so living
here in the most industrialized part of
the industrialized World our tentacles
reach everywhere
foreign
efficacy is the ability to produce a
desired result
but are the results we're achieving the
ones we intend
wild animals are disappearing forever
our intelligence is remaking the world
before our eyes
today we can just click on a link
somewhere and have something appear at
our doorstep without having any idea of
what went into getting it there
all we know about what got it there is
the price we get more and more detached
from the actual cost of creating and
transporting what we're using
[Music]
energy is really at the center of
physics but for the late person probably
the easiest way to explain it is that
energy is the ability to do work
work is forced through distance
so every time that you move something
from China to the U.S or from the floor
to the ceiling that takes energy when
you drive to work obviously it takes
energy to boil one quart of water takes
up the equivalent of 500 calories of
food
any kind of transformation requires
energy we are powerful creatures on this
planet but we still need the ecosystem
to survive so we don't want to destroy
the ecosystem because it would be rather
bad
and this is a transition you can call
with also Revolution you can come with a
whatever you like
the point is that there have been such
revolutions as transitions in the past
but these transitions have a cost an
energy transition must be paid in energy
energy is the currency of life
energy creates movement from food
[Music]
old life Taps energy flows
we used to measure units of energy in
terms of horsepower
one horse could do the work of Ten Men
[Music]
small tractor can do the work of 40
horses
I would take 450 horses or more to get
the same work done as just one semi
truck
and unlike horses trucks can work day
and night in any weather
the flow of fossil fuel has turbocharged
our society
and so to just say
we have the science now to realize that
these fossil slaves they don't complain
they don't sleep they're tireless
they're super strong but they poop and
they breathe and their breath is causing
our biosphere to warm up and our oceans
to acidify let's keep them in the ground
it's not quite so simple
if you consider the power that's in
fossil fuels
90 percent of the work done in human
economies is done by fossil slaves
the average American consumes 220
000 kilocalories every day we don't
think about that we only think about the
3 000 or 3500 of food that we eat
but our energy footprint is almost 100
times more than that if you consider our
buses and our airplanes and all the
hospitals and the Disneylands and the
NASCARs and in all the various things
that we buy that are imported all around
the world
it's what people invest in and a lot of
Pension funds and a lot of the
institutions that so much of humanity
depends on of course they gravitate
toward oil renewable energy although
it's mature and it's getting very cheap
it's not going to replace this
infrastructure and this civilization
we have a very limited amount of time to
transition to a low-carbon economy but
it's very naive to just say let's keep
it in the ground and keep everything
else running
so if you ask
cancer Energy power our society as it is
today then you already have the answer
it is no it is not possible if you want
to switch from oil and gas and coal and
to move to solar energy then you have to
change a lot of things our food system
right now is an energy sink we use 10 to
12 fossil calories to produce One Food
calorie right now we have around 100
trillion dollars worth of Machinery on
the planet that uses gasoline or diesel
fuel
so for one barrel of oil which we pay
fifty dollars for we have
thousands of fossil slaves standing
behind us
the American
inventory of automobiles 250 270 million
cars and light trucks on the road
you're talking about more than a decade
of production and you're talking about
more wealth than the gross domestic
product in a year to replace it so
you're not going to do these make these
changes overnight you see there is a
parameter which is very basic in
evaluating these kind of things
which is called Energy return on energy
invested energy doesn't cost dollars
I mean it does but it really cost energy
oil is the biggest industry on the
planet
so it sets the pace in terms of
inflation so if you raise the price of
oil all the other prices go up until
people have accommodated and they can
still afford to buy the pay the
extraction cost for oil
so it's not like we're running out of
oil
or coal or gas it's that it's getting
more costly in energy terms to get it
because it's more costly it has less
benefits to the rest of society the
1930s the Beverly hillbilly oil just
bubbling under the ground we've used all
that
net energy which is the energy left
after we pay the energy cost of finding
and extracting it
net energy is is declining now
we don't realize
the scale and the stakes of what's
happening when we take on debt we are
promising to repay it with Future Energy
the fossil fuels will not last forever
they cannot last forever the energy
potential in one barrel of oil
is equal to a human being working 40
hours a week for four and a half years
foreign
you have to think to the Future you have
to save something for the future in
order to have a harvest of renewable
energy do not eat your seed corn with an
old saying
wise Farmers know that if they eat their
Seed corn there will be nothing left to
plant for a future Harvest
will future Generations look back at
today and view much of the energy we're
burning to have been wasted
are we eating our Seed corn
so many of us have come to expect a
level of comfort and convenience
unprecedented in our biological past
[Music]
we need to redefine our expectations not
as what we will lose
but what we might gain by preparing for
something different
oh fossil fuels are bad we need to keep
them in the ground so we've got this big
divestment campaign where we stop
investing in coal and oil and natural
gas but if we stop investing in the
stocks as long as we continue to fly and
drive and have infrastructure built
around cheap Transportation
Global connectivity of of Supply chains
then some hedge fund will just buy those
stocks back five cents cheaper we can
very easily get into the mode for
example when we think about oil of
addiction speech I'm going to leave this
bottle of whiskey in the cupboard and
I'm not going to touch a drop of it
which means that I'm still fixated on
this whiskey paradoxically this is
actually of course not really thinking
differently
is a little bit of a hangover from this
myth that things should be functioning
smoothly and that smooth functioning is
something that's real
[Music]
if you find yourself in 10 or 20 years
from now in a world where energy isn't
cheap you're going to have to unwind
somehow this massive Global City system
so then you look back in history to
times when this has happened before I
mean the Roman Empire
one of the reasons it fell was it was no
longer able to continue to bring in food
and other supplies to Rome and the other
big city states
and cities no longer were habitable they
just didn't function anymore
so what happens this time around
and in the past it's been conflict with
other tribes that has brought human
progress such as it is at a tremendous
cost of Slaughter
World War One brought forth radio and
and airplanes World War II gave us
nuclear energy
space race between the United States and
the Soviet Union the cold war that gave
us communication satellites and global
positioning and many other things and
now we're into something where we have
to work collectively we can't work
against each other we have to work with
each other we have to work with each
other with the view of the future not
against each other in the present
the trouble is not so much in what we're
thinking about the world we live in it's
in terms of how we think about the world
we live in
well here we have a human brain
when you see it in reality it seems kind
of a bit disappointing doesn't it it's
very small for what it does if you think
about what we're capable of and to think
it all comes out of a little object like
that it's quite remarkable
let's take a moment to imagine entering
a theoretical world where everything in
existence at all scales has equal value
from skyscrapers and trees to humans
Cola cups and orangutans
cases
vessels
water
diamonds and dragonflies
even time itself
if we can imagine everything as
intrinsically equal
know that what we perceive is reality
comes from the value judgments that
exist in our minds
[Music]
if everything exists in the same way
then we have an interesting problem
if it's true that even just by existing
I'm killing a huge number of life forms
then I have to figure out what kinds of
life forms I'd like to kill and I have
to be rather conscious and explicit
about it and being conscious and
explicit about stuff is an incredible
drag
there's always an unintended consequence
of what you're doing for example
reality is happening on a number of
different scales all at once
you can never get it completely right
so we're confronted again with the
notion of exploring various different
shades of hypocrisy you know the famous
study if I offer you twenty dollars oh
yeah yeah or I can give you fifty
dollars in a week's time you've always
people just kind of are almost kind of
compelled to go for the short term goal
for the short term yeah and if you think
about it up to a point that's very
rational because you could be dead
that's right you don't know who's gonna
so
um the bird in the hand worth two in
them absolutely so there's some
rationality to that discounting
organisms that worried about 50 years
from now were out competed by organisms
that were at about five minutes from now
our faith is in our own hands
no one no one else
how will we shape the future towards a
better outcome
what defines our identity
[Music]
how we are urges
foreign
are we our principles
who are we
who I am is really
the accumulation of my experiences with
other people my interactions with other
people
babies don't have a self-concept they
don't
of an idea of who they are
but as they interact with other people
they begin to create an image of
themselves
of a feeling of who they are and
thoughts about who they are
that's really picked up from the views
and responses of other people
[Music]
in this modern society people spend a
large amount of time and effort
accumulating objects and possessions and
sometimes these have no particular use
whatsoever but it's almost as if we have
to acquire things around us to make a
statement of who we are we use objects
as an extension of ourself
in the life of sentient beings desire is
inevitable
um the kind of plastic products that
consumerism makes out of Desire might be
optional but desire is inevitable that
same drive is what makes it easy for
Apple to sell us a new iPhone every year
I mean I guarantee you you don't need
the next iPhone in fact you don't even
know what new features it's going to
have and you won't know until you see
them but you you're pretty sure that
you're going to like them when you see
them and that was the whole point of
this notion of dynamic obsolescence
you would be allowed to feel to achieve
a certain emotional state for a short
period of time and then almost as
quickly as you'd achieved it it would
begin fading you'd have to have
something else
you have a real love for a way to feel
how we want to feel faster
[Music]
we may have a very developed conscious
mind today with a lot of knowledge
cultural knowledge technical knowledge
but the way we think is still very much
influenced by A Primitive unconscious
that we developed
millions of years ago
[Music]
aren't just like animals we are animals
and as animals we compete for mates
organisms in the wild that have extra
resources to display like flashy Tails
or large antlers are advertising to
their mates that my genes are so good
I don't need to skimp and save because
I'm so strong I have these amazing
attributes
same phenomenon happens in
societies to impress members of the
opposite sex
a lot of these displays require spending
extra energy and natural resources that
we don't really need to be genetically
fit
respond to those cultural signals as if
those things really do matter
this question of status and of showing
our status
I I do believe that that's one of the
most fundamental determinants of our
Behavior
well you know who knows this best of all
it's the marketing and the advertising
people because when they're selling us
stuff and it's designer or what they're
tapping into is this preoccupation with
what other people think because they
understand intuitively that we're all
animals seeking social status
we like things to be convenient we like
things to be new and we like bags that
have names on it we like to drink out of
bottles that we can throw away we like
styrofoam containers for our fast food
plastic itself is something that is
persistent through time hopefully gets
recycled it gets recycled it gets
smaller it gets smaller and now it's
right back to us and detectable in our
bloodstream
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
with what we hear and we understand and
we know what's going on
and the life that I am leading including
all the things I love that might be
really ecologically problematic but that
I love them anyways so we have this very
positive spin on ourself and we try to
maintain that characterization to the
extent that we will only pay attention
to information which confirms that bias
we'll deliberately reframe things that
we've done in order to keep the
coherence of Who We Are
[Music]
our brains are always creating these
these distortions we have no direct
contact with reality one of the
important qualities that we developed
that helped us survive was group
identity
and today group identity still plays an
important role in our life
and has an important unconscious effect
on our attitudes and our actions so we
have this tendency always to sort of
attribute blame to others rather than
accepting ourselves and this is part of
the bias which creates or keeps us this
coherence of this being a good person
[Music]
capable of running around with the wrong
idea of what is really going on in our
world
and there is no mechanism or voice
inside us to Signal the artificiality of
that
we don't want to live in a state of
anxiety we want to believe that the
things we enjoy doing will never change
don't we confuse what we need with what
we desire and what we desire with what
we need
desire is logically prior to need
actually a need is really just like
stabilized desire that's been turned
probably socially into something
seemingly necessary and so I think we
need to be a little bit careful when we
talk about
being in an ecological Society meaning
our needs matching up with what we want
so there's this constant
being the inhibitory centers that know
what's good for us in the top of the
brain particularly the prefrontal area
and the midbrain areas for emotional
impulse which just wants to grab that
yummy thing and have it now
so let's say we're in a bakery
everything looks so good and our brain
which during Evolution was designed to
Crave fat and sugar is going nuts it
just really wants one of those yummy
things but then our prefrontal cortex
the part of the brain that learns the
part of the brain that understands says
to us you know this is fattening and you
have that blood sugar problem it's not
so great for you and the prefrontal
cortex has the ability to inhibit
emotional impulse and once we understand
the true cost of the things we use and
the things we do to the environment the
very same mechanism applies
and lets us pull back to the balcony of
the mine where we see everything that's
going on then we can make a better
decision this is the first step in
changing our habits because without
mindfulness we don't even notice the
Choice points we just blindly
spontaneously automatically do that
thing we've always done our old habits
take us over when there's uncertainty
when there's a sense of precarity when
there's a feeling of vulnerability and
confusion
that's exactly when we are most
susceptible obviously
to adhering to a message a voice a
person
who comes along and is able to meet
those anxieties and those uncertainties
with such confidence and certainty and
so that's what we've seen replaying over
and over again in politics
[Music]
thank you
I don't need to mention the obvious
examples of what happens when
the you know larger publics
sense of fear
is co-opted about half the wealth of the
country is held by the top one percent
of the people and a lot of us out there
and my parents were certainly one of
them who were scrambling from day to day
to survive and they in their lifetimes
in the 1930s had actually seen people
starving because they couldn't order a
living and uh and so most Americans
haven't seen that but some Americans
still feel that way and they feel the
threat and the fear of unemployment so
they're focused near term
you know in any symbiosity relationship
who's the top and who's the bottom is a
little bit confusing you know and and
this could collapse at any moment
[Music]
the desire to be rescued is based on a
profound and deep sense of powerlessness
[Music]
open up a paper or watch a conventional
ecological documentary and what you'll
see are all kinds of facts designed to
make you feel scared and upset and
guilty
this is how we talk to ourselves about
ecological disaster now the trouble is
that that means that psychologically
we're actually still putting ourselves
before a time when it happened somehow
allowing ourselves the choice to either
go down that path or not you know the
point is we're already down the path
when we on the climate science side talk
about the reality of climate change at
first blush it sounds like a bit of a
downer so one's natural reaction if you
hear bad news and someone else tells you
no no no no that's not true is to at
least sort of say hope that the guy
who's telling you that this is not going
to happen
is right for six years uh in Congress I
said that climate change was nonsense I
really didn't know anything about it
and so I represented probably the
reddest district and the right estate
the nation
I knew that I needed to be opposed to it
and my son came to me he was voting for
the first time he just turned 18 and he
said to me Dad I'll vote for you
but you're going to clean up your act on
the environment
your child is sick
98 doctors say treat him this way
two say no this other is the way to go
I'll go with the two
you're taking a big risk of those kids
some people think that what we have here
is an information deficit that if we
just gave people more scientific
information showed them the science then
they would come around oh we got people
that make a living and a lot of money on
talk radio and talk TV
pronouncing all kinds of things they
slept at Holiday Inn Express last night
and they are now experts on climate it's
an identification problem it's it's it
doesn't look like my tribe doesn't sound
like my tribe doesn't sound like our war
cry doesn't sound like our song
too often it's presented climate science
is presented as though this is some kind
of new religion and you've got to
believe
no don't ask people to believe in
climate science I just say here's some
data
now what is your faith tradition tell
you about what to do with that data in
mine it tells me that I'm a steward of
this glorious creation
sometimes science turns out to be wrong
but other times it turns out to be very
right
and the key to Scientific Endeavor is
what we're here to discuss today is
openness
access to the data in full
challenging of the data that's how we
advance science I look forward to
hearing Mr chairman thank you for the
opportunity thank you there have been
major Revolutions in our thinking across
civilization for example for thousands
of years it was thought that the Earth
was at the center of the universe we now
know that's not true and then of course
there was also the idea that man is the
Pinnacle of of the animal kingdom but
now we discover through natural
selection and darwinianism that we are
just one but a number of species that
have existed and finally if you think
about the self the idea that we are
individuals in control of all our
actions and behaviors that has been
eroded away as we come to discover that
this in fact is also not entirely true
so I think that the science has revealed
the arrogance of the individualism that
the egocentrism that we have about our
planet our species and ourselves is is
unwarranted
ecology
it's a word derived from the Greek Oikos
or household
it's the study of the relationships that
Interlink all the members of the Earth's
household
we can't think of ecology as only
existing over there Beyond because it
has no boundaries and is in a state of
constant flux
ecology is intimate coming right up to
our skin and through it it's permeable
and borderless and chaotic
the internal and the external are always
entwined
so when we speak about sustainability
what is it that we hope to sustain
[Music]
one of the problems with philosophy is
that it isn't just in your head
philosophy is everywhere
everything in a way was a dream in
someone's head in build space
thought isn't just something that's in
here thought is everywhere
the story that we live in right now is
that we grow the economy by consuming
goods and in particular consuming Goods
[Music]
that exist in limited quantities we have
the tendency
as meaning making story making
people
creatures to have characters to have
protagonists who are the villains and
who are the heroes and The Rescuers and
that's deep in our human psyche and
that's how we tend to make sense of the
world and the tendency very
understandably is to create villains
such as corporations or oil Industries
and to create Heroes the Eco Warriors
while that's understandable what it's
actually doing is it's creating a bit of
an exemption story where we as
individuals
are somewhat exempt or somewhat out of
the story
there's a lot of criticism in our
culture right now that capitalism is bad
and that we would without capitalism we
wouldn't be impacting things and that's
partially true
[Music]
underpinning this system is the optimal
foraging Instinct that resides in our
animal natures
foreign
they're better off running down an elk
than spending the same amount of time
and energy chasing a mouse or a rabbit
they're more evolutionarily fit and have
more calories to raise their offspring
the same Dynamic is in humans
we like to invest
the return
we do this in stock markets when we get
a 20 discount on shoes
a two-for-one cocktail at happy hour or
a steal of a deal buying a house on some
special foreclosure
capitalism isn't entirely good or bad
capitalism is in service of the super
organisms
[Music]
together we're functioning like a
gigantic wolf pack hungry for more
energy
you know one of the many causes of war
is actually the shortage of energy
energy is always flowing from like a
kind of compacted state to a less
compacted state
entropy is how things are constantly
running down to zero
we can't actually create a machine that
reverses entropy
entropy is why time seems to only be
going in One Direction
entropy is why you've never seen a
broken glass reassemble as a perfect
glass
and if you're looking for the perfect
ecological machine that will actually
fully put the energy back into the
system that the machine is sucked out of
it then I'm afraid you're going to be
waiting until the after the end of the
universe
so you always have to leave room in your
analysis of animals and animals in the
Brighton to include people in that
of thinking that we're always going to
do the right thing of that we've
optimized all of our actions our
foraging strategies and everything else
and we can extrapolate from there
because if we had everything right there
wouldn't be any problems with there
there'd be no property there'd be no
climate change there'd be no Warfare
where you sit determines where you stand
and if you're
If you're sort of all tied up in a
particular kind of industry and you see
your future there
naturally you hold on
there's no such thing as a free market I
hope people can understand that because
in if if there were free markets you'd
end up the way we ended up in the late
1800s with a few very powerful trusts
controlling all of America
without government
helping us shape the market forces the
market forces will be taken by the very
short-term requirements that are placed
on them by us
by her need to go to the filling station
and get the cheapest fuel by the need
for the pension fund to get its eight
percent return no matter what it's
investing in
really tough to earn the six or seven
percent or eight percent per year that
were in those Actuarial calculations
when the Pension funds were established
so it's not some foreign institution
that makes us be short-term focused it's
it's us why didn't the administration
anticipate the uh energy crisis several
years ago formulate a positive action
plan to do something about it have to
bring a different perspective to this
a couple of years ago I asked a member
of Congress I said what's the toughest
issue you're dealing with right now
she said
Federal subsidies for
Seashore flood insurance because we've
always subsidized it and the cost of the
subseas is going way up and people
insist on buying these homes that are
subject to title erosion into flooding
and to destruction ultimately
there isn't transparent accountable
pricing for all the impacts of the
burning of fossil fuels
the markets still aren't working right
and one says cost are revealed and put
at the meter and put on the pump
then consumers will make choices that
are in their self-interest
will be making
Transportation fuel on our roofs of
course I'm not saying that we get to
Nirvana and we don't have any War one of
the causes of War would be less
because energy would be more abundantly
available and more distributed around
the world
if we're going to live up to our name
Homo sapiens which means wise man we'll
have to understand our subconscious
motivations our unconscious desires and
justifications
and the true cost of energy
when you look at the past you're looking
at a decision
decisions about how to live in the world
the people in the past made
it may be technically true that we don't
know everything about where our food
came from
we keep telling ourselves it's difficult
but just read the back of the cereal
package it tells you where all the stuff
is and then you can figure out where it
came from on Google
from what countries do the raw materials
for an iPhone come from
hey there you go
but here's a double Testament the
commodity chain
foreign
[Music]
we know that certain things that we do
now turn on certain parts of our brain
or Inspire certain kinds of attitude or
inculcate certain kinds of response so
however we want to talk about it we
could think of the kind of fire that
consumerism lights up in us with all of
the desires as a kind of gateway to more
desires that might be actually more
interesting and More in sync with other
life forms
when you think about the universe as the
flow of energy
then that simply changes your whole
perspective about what it is to be alive
all living systems require energy
as individuals if we think more
strategically about how we're using a
planet's energy
life would be better for every living
thing
you know individual behavior Can emerge
as something different at a different
scale
emergence is sort of interactive
we don't need 24 7 access to energy we
need 24 7 access to feelings we can just
approach each other with without the
sort of condescension that comes
way too often when we come to
environmental topics
and say all right so we're looking for
something to work one of the important
aspects of the evolution of cooperation
is the development of complex moral
emotions so sympathy empathy compassion
and these are the key I think this is
vital to our understanding of The Human
Condition
the morphological adaptations that we
have are simply reflections of where our
ancestors arose on a planet
how much sun did they get how much
oxygen was in the air these determine
the shapes of their skulls the color of
their skin but it has nothing to do with
the inherent essence of what it means to
be
because we're all the same species
[Music]
been pretty wonderful Journey for
mankind but boy what a wonderful
set of issues to have to wrestle with
going forward we don't even have to get
the alpha centuri to find these issues
and learn about ourselves and develop
how do we look at long-term problems can
we embody the wisdom that we feel is
inherent here and move into the future
wisely
in our council at Onondaga when we
looked into the future
and we addressed ourselves and says
crossed the fire
so I understand
they asked
one of the old Chiefs my uncle I said
what does that actually mean and it
means the leaders I said no it's a real
literal translation
he says it means you who look far in the
future
and the left side
Quality Base is the eagle has landed
astronaut Neil Armstrong pursuing the
next step in the evolution of our
knowledge when he returned from one of
Mankind's greatest engineering
achievements stated I felt a successful
lunar Landing might Inspire men around
the world to believe that impossible
goals are possible that there really is
hope for the future of mankind
we are living in the Future's Past and
the relative odds of future outcomes
change every second
the world we all live in is not larger
than the sum of its parts
each part is neither the center or the
edge
it's a bustling World a household of
beings colleagues
both human and non-human animate and
inanimate over which we have influence
but in turn influence us
[Music]
physical realities exist regardless of
our desires
insignificant actions taken collectively
have led us to this moment
[Music]
everything is a system of relationships
and it's not easy to see the connections
the connections between the paint on a
bar
in different asphalt
press conference
or to see the invisible links between
human expectations
human vulnerability
human memory
and the fragility of life itself
now it requires effort
[Music]
energy comes in many forms
it's both the means and the ends of all
our Pursuits
all of us held in the arms of the
atmosphere
we don't have to be poets scientists
superheroes or Saints each of us can
think about how we think
could the solution we're looking for be
inside us
we're humankind
Ingenuity is in our DNA and we can
visualize
what kind of future would you like to
see
what are you willing to contribute
towards creating that future
ask yourself what am I willing to do
and not something that requires more
effort than you're willing to make and
not some small contribution that just
scratches the guilt it's but doesn't get
the job done no ask yourself
what am I willing to contribute that
comes natural to me
something that I can sustain until the
challenge has been met
something that fits into my life
my profession my hobbies
fits in with my relationships
something that's a part of who I am
you know each of us
is unique each of us has a gift
a strength that we can direct towards
creating this world
that we'd like to see in our future
that we'd like to see in our kids in
descendants future
we love our kids right
a quote from the religious philosopher
Pierre teljad desjadon comes to mind
after mastering the winds the waves the
tides and gravity
we shall harness for God the energy of
love
and then for a second time in the
history of the world
men will have discovered fire
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign